you know who's doing it right your one  single friend who never seems to date  yet still manages to get laid all the  time he's just slanting Monday through  Friday you know the one everyone has  that friend kudos to you seriously hats  off your ability to not think twice  about potentially being alone for the  rest of your life is admirable to say  the least and you probably have it all  don't you free time killer savings just  freedom I don't know how you do it just  teach me teach please teach me I want to  learn master just I need this now if  you'll excuse me I have to go get ready  for a date that I am super stoked for  like grinning ear to ear just heaven man  I can't wait